there are some major developments today
and in the days ahead on the vaccine
front first on booster shots the fda is
expected to authorize mixing and
matching as soon as today
so far only the pfizer booster has been
given the green light however the cdc
committee is meeting today and tomorrow
to consider shots from johnson and
johnson and moderna fda approval for
those is expected this week
also if you have young children pay
attention to the very first week of
november that's when the cdc is meeting
to talk about vaccinating kids ages 5 to
11. if approved the pfizer vaccine would
be the very first made available in
those cases
a vocal group of first responders are
pushing back against vaccine mandates
we've seen protests in los angeles over
a mandate for city workers elsewhere
some police officers and firefighters
have chosen to resign and new york just
announced a new vaccine requirement
affecting police officers jeff pogueis
is following this from washington jeff
good morning
that announcement made by the mayor of
new york city likely sparking the kind
of debate that we've seen in other
cities over this issue because how
firefighters and officers respond to
these mandates could ultimately
determine how quickly they get to the
scenes of emergencies
late yesterday seattle police officers
and firefighters walked up city hall
steps to turn in their boots they
refused to comply with a state mandate
to get vaccinated i'm wrapping up my
last shift after 20 years
in spokane tim archer gave up his job
i'll be fired
tonight by the city of spokane he also
refuse to get vaccinated
why didn't you comply i really felt like
this is in violation
of the civil rights
that god has given us
there has been a wave of resignations
and firings in fire and police
departments across the country
los angeles fire reports there have been
at least 241 separations from the
department
baltimore's police department is down
279
officers and in the last couple of years
seattle police had more than 300
officers separate from the department
in massachusetts the state police union
president is threatening that at least
150 state police will resign what kind
of impact could this have we'll have
slower responses there'll be case
backlogs
processing of evidence
everything from you know house calls to
an alarm burglary call i just haven't
seen the data to support that but that's
not what's playing out in some cities
like chicago where a mandate is already
in place
only 21 sworn officers and civilian
workers are not being paid for failing
to comply and that's out of 13 000 on
the workforce eight out of ten are
vaccinated officers have come to work
we've been fully staffed
there hasn't been
a shift that's been short
there hasn't been this 30 40 50 percent
shortage that i've heard from various
sources
in the midst of this very heated debate
it is worth noting
that there are still ongoing challenges
related to the pandemic for officers on
the front lines in fact according to the
officer down memorial page govid remains
the leading cause of death for police
officers nearly five times higher than
the number killed by
gunfire
wow those numbers are very staggering
thank you very much jeff